[Music]
Kim Kardashian and Haley Bieber show a
united front after the beauty mogul's ex
Kanye West slammed the model on social
media those women are amazing and
they're some of my closest friends the
leaves posed together multiple times at
a Tiffany and Co event in Los Angeles
they both opted for Chic black ensembles
Kim opted for a coat while Haley went a
bit more exposed yeah that's me the
outing comes just days after Kanye
attacked Haley on social media for
defending Vogue editor Gabriella karifa
Johnson who spoke out against EA's Paris
Fashion Week show which featured
controversial shirts with the message
White lives matter you can't lean on
these big companies to to give your
vision you know if you're the if you're
the smartest person in the room you're
in the wrong room
and how do you feel now having done this
I feel the same
at war in a sense to lead a post Kanye
called the model Haley bald loose and
claimed she got a nose job before
telling her husband Justin Bieber get
your girl before I get mad you're
supposed to be my friend right take this
haters as for how JB responded well A
source told E.T Justin's distancing
himself from the rapper if your core
Foundation isn't supporting you then
you're just gonna
is you're just not going to be balanced
you know I think that that's it just
shows how much I care you know the
singer says he has been a true friend of
Kanye and tried to empathize with him in
the past but this crossed the line that
he's not okay with quote Justin is very
protective over Haley and he is upset by
Kanye's attack on her where he said
hurtful and untrue things I think just
being kind at the end of the day is what
separates you from others and in the
days following that drama Kanye
continued to stir up controversy making
several anti-semitic remarks the Jewish
media was pushing the narrative off the
White live White lives matter t-shirt
that I didn't love black people and I
just came off and I came back and I was
like no the Jewish media and Kim she
wasn't standing for it denouncing his
comments in a statement reading in part
quote I stand together with the Jewish
Community you know where I'm at in my
life now if I can influence people in
other ways
and just to take something that's close
to their heart and use their platform to
speak up that's what's really important
to me Kanye's Behavior now being met
with consequences he's lost deals with
valenciaga gap and Adidas despite him
saying this before they dropped him I
could literally say anti-semitic and
they can't drop me
I could say anti-semitic things and
Adidas can't drop me
now what
now what Kanye's social media accounts
were enabled Wednesday night after
previously being suspended this first
post back well it was titled love speech
and in it he claims to have lost two
billion dollars in a day
foreign